Donald Trump resurfaced yesterday on Fox
news's Sean Hannity program and told
many of the same corrosive lies that
he's been telling about the 2020
election since November and why wouldn't
we expect that Trump was still telling
the same corrosive and debunked lies
about the 2016 election as recently as
January if Trump still hasn't accepted
the results of the 2016 election why on
Earth would we expect him to accept the
results of the 2020 election everything
about this interview is hilarious here
is Sean Hannity introducing it Sean
Hannity framing this as a major
exclusive but if you're watching you
will see Trump doesn't even seem pleased
to be sitting for this interview well
tonight for the hour we welcome the 45th
president of the United States Donald
Trump Mr President good to see you
thanks for joining us well thank you
very much John all right okay so now
they get into what we could call the
substance although there wasn't very
much substance and here Trump jumps
right into proof
debunkable easily disprovable lies that
in presidential re-elections presidents
tend to get fewer votes in their
re-election than in their first election
it's just not true
we're going to look at the numbers but
watch Trump use the lie to somehow I
guess continue making the case that Joe
Biden didn't really win many other
things the big thing is taxes low taxes
no taxes you're going to have the
biggest tax increase you've ever seen a
pro-life Second Amendment so many
different things now I I hate to cut in
already
the tax increase Joe Biden is looking at
would not be the biggest in history
Trump did barely a thing on abortion
Trump did nothing on the Second
Amendment okay let's go to the core of
it though that
look we got 75 million votes it's more
than any sitting president in history by
far the word was if we got 65 to 66 you
know we got 63 the first time in one
if you got 65 to 66 there was no way you
lost we got more votes we got 12 million
more votes than we got and it's never
happened to another president I don't
know if you know Sean usually in a
second term a president gets less votes
I got 12 million more it's the biggest
that's ever happened in history from 63
to 75
never happened before and all of these
things are good these are popular things
but more important than popular they're
great things for this country they're
going to rip apart your second amendment
now first of all it is fewer votes not
less votes Mr President but let's not
start the grammar policing I know he
only went to Wharton but what Trump says
is not true Trump says presidents
typically get fewer votes in their
re-elections check out the numbers Obama
did get fewer votes he lost 4 million
votes from 2008 to 2012. but George W
bush gained 12 million votes in his
re-election Bill Clinton gained 3
million votes Ronald Reagan gained 11
million votes Richard Nixon gained 16
million votes and Dwight D Eisenhower
gained a million votes so really other
than Barack Obama you have to go back to
World War II for a president whose votes
declined after their first term and it's
kind of a weird example it's an
exception to the rule it's FDR who had
four terms and whose presidency in so
many ways was the exception to the rule
maybe what Trump means is
Obama got fewer votes in the second term
and we know Trump is obsessed with
Barack Obama maybe that's all that this
is really about but an easily
disprovable Lie from Donald Trump check
out this suck up question from Sean
Hannity it's not even really a question
it's like a gushing statement of praise
the likes of which you'd expect from
North Korean television sort of like a
Mr President can you confirm how hard
you're working right so I know a lot of
people that are around you every day
this is what they're all telling me
you're working as hard as you did when
you were in the white house except you
play a little golf more
that you you're keeping an insane
schedule
seven days a week
you really don't stop
well we're seeing a lot of people we're
seeing a lot of good Republicans and a
lot of good Americans in some cases
great Americans and Hannity is doing the
equivalent of Kim Jong-un bold for the
first time today and he bowled the 300
he also turned water into wine this
apparently counts as an interview on Fox
news now I told you yesterday that the
treasury Department put out a report
confirming coordination between Donald
Trump's 2016 campaign chairman Paul
manafort and a Russian intelligence
officer Constantine kilimnick the topic
of Russia came up
and Trump says something completely
unintelligible but he does do the sir
routine where he claims someone came to
me and they said sir take a look at this
you did run and did win
what would you do differently
um
when I came in we were hit with phony
Russia Russia Russia investigations
it was a total phony deal that was three
years here presidency I've been I've
been fighting off investigations
for five years I mean really since the
almost the day that we came down and
they were corrupt
Democrat inspired I still have it they
were Democrat inspired investigations
Russia I remember Sean and I don't have
too much time I guess with you but a
story I think it's interesting I haven't
told it before
during the campaign in 2016 I'd be asked
like by one of our aides sir do you have
anything to do with Russia
I say no no that would be it then a
month later somebody would say
what do you know about Russia
I said now what I don't know what you're
talking about okay I wouldn't think of
it then after three or four or five
times people would say
anything about Russia
I kept saying after three or four times
I said what's going on with Russia
they created a phony deal it was paid
for by Hillary crooked Hillary Clinton
they made a phony Russian disinformation
destroyed oh and they used it to spy on
you as a candidate correct your
transition team and while you were
president it says at the top of a fisa
warrant verified it was unverifiable and
they knew it 17 times they knew it right
from the get-go I don't know what either
of them are talking about but they seem
to be kind of playing off of each other
and winding each other up here's a few
more seconds from this portion of the
interview they knew they were warm
beforehand and they knew it certainly
from Christopher Steele and the sub
Source by January total fraud and you
know what it did it hurt any possibility
of dealing with Russia we could have we
could have had a good look they'll say
oh he loves Russia
getting along with Russia is a good
thing not a bad thing getting along with
China is a good thing the problem now
when Trump was asked whether he will run
again this just like he can't answer any
question normally he said that from a
legal standpoint he doesn't really want
to talk about that
I I say this I I am looking at it very
seriously Beyond seriously from a legal
standpoint I don't want to really talk
about it yet it's a little too if you
did run what does that even mean from a
legal standpoint like part of me thinks
it has to do with Trump wanting to use
donations as a slush fund for his
personal expenses I don't know why my
mind goes to that but like what could he
even mean from a legal standpoint and
then Trump was also asked about
Republican vaccine hesitancy and Trump
said he doesn't really know why
Republicans are hesitant to take the
vaccine for covid take a look
you know they all want me to do a
commercial because a lot of our people
don't want to take vaccine you know I
don't know what that is exactly
Republican I don't know what it is you
encourage people to get I encourage them
to take it I do but they want me to make
a video did you get it they yes I did
they went I had it and I took it okay
you got both because I believe so here's
here's the thing they want me to do a
commercial Trump can't imagine why
Republicans wouldn't be getting the
vaccine because for a year Trump said
this wasn't serious if something's not
serious why would anybody need a vaccine
that's why there's so much vaccine
hesitancy so just a completely bizarre
interview and unclear what the point of
it is I guess Sean Hannity wants ratings
and Trump wants attention like maybe
it's that simple and we don't need to
analyze the motivations more deeply but
expect much more of this if Donald
Trump's q and on Congressional allies
get reelected in 2022 Trump will be
reinvigorated you're going to see this
much more regularly and it may be what
gets Donald Trump to run in 2024 as
we've talked about before so very
important that we ensure Trump doesn't
get his people you know Marjorie Taylor
Greene and Lauren bobert Madison
cawthorne the Jim Jordan yeah whoever
anybody that can be removed in 2022 will
make it less likely that Trump even runs
in 2024. one of our sponsors today is
blue blocks I spend a lot of time
because of my work looking at a computer
screen and peer-reviewed Studies have
shown that the blue light that comes
from screens can actually lead to
certain types of eye strain and even
damage or blurred vision headaches dry
watery eyes blue blocks fixes this by
filtering out the blue light and unlike
other cheap blue light glasses the
effectiveness of blue blocks glasses are
backed up by evidence and they're built
under Optics laboratory conditions these
are my blue blocks glasses I like how
they look they have over 40 different
styles to choose from I really have
noticed a a big difference where I'm no
longer getting that eye strain and
headaches from the computer screen
because of the blue blocks glasses they
have prescription versions and
non-prescription and readers they have
something for every need and blue blocks
is giving you 20 off when you go to
blueblocks.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is under this video and
you'll get free shipping on orders over
115 dollars